software is fundamentally changing and
if you look at the israeli companies
like whenever the cloud providers are
putting out a new feature
you see the israeli companies grabbing
it first playing with it
adopting it and then making it better
right welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford these next 20 minutes are going
to be all about the israeli tech scene
all about investing society what needs
to happen what is happening
and why ben is so excited about being
the
managing partner and founder of
amityventures ben is the founder and
managing partner of amityventures
a u.s israel venture firm founded in
amity has seated or been an early stage
investor of innovas
psychognito next silicon valance vyar
demo stack data loop and many more
previously at auto codes ben had
responsibilities that included
m a product strategy product marketing
business development and north american
operations
he also acted as a general manager of
acquired companies among other
responsibilities
ben has an mba from georgetown
university ben roberts thank you for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
how are you i'm good how are you i love
your office
we're on the we're on a very very high
floor
of the rochelle 22 i have a little bit
of fear of heights but the
view from here is spectacular and and i
just love coming here the atmosphere is
so great you're investing in such
incredible companies
i met with your partner modi before and
i'm great friends with dave and i can't
wait to now meet you
in these 20 minutes you founded amity i
believe 11 years ago
u.s israeli vc with some pretty clear
thesis as to
what types of companies you want to
invest in from what i'm saying
throughout the investments and
throughout the funds there's a pretty
clear trajectory as to what interests
you and how you think of the world
and so tell me about a bit about the
founding of a meeting
what led you to to to think of this firm
okay sure
well first thanks for coming and and
you're safe so don't have any fears here
um so 11 years ago was like during a
terrible economic crisis a huge
financial crisis in the world it was
coming after
um with mortgages and the banks being in
trouble and then
spreading through through the rest of
the world through all kinds of economies
and i was kind of contrarian at the time
thinking this site is a really good time
to start a company this is a great time
to be an entrepreneur and be a founder
and i want to play offense not while
everyone's playing defense
israel at that time if you look at the
venture community
uh there's different reports about what
the numbers were but it ranges from
maybe
800 million dollars maybe a little over
a billion dollars was the size of all
venture being invested in this that's
it in the year 2010 which you know for
those that don't know in comparison
today it's not strange to have a month
of you know 1.3
1.5 billion dollars of venture investing
literally
10 11 x right so huge hugely but at that
point
the vcs had to really focus on their
portfolio companies keep them alive
get through the crisis and there was
very little
um uh new investing happening in terms
of you know companies that were getting
started so
so i just thought it was a great time uh
to jump in
of course for years i've been preparing
myself i had
you know bought companies through you
know i was working previous companies i
was working with i would be
doing m a and i buy companies i'd run
then the the companies we acquired or
i done product strategy i dealt with
investors i had
dealt with a lot of things that you
needed to be a very success you know to
be a successful vc in terms of
operational experience investor
experience
investing itself so i had the tools
and then the timing seemed to me right
um of course the challenge is then how
do you find investors that want to play
offense when they're scared
um and they're they've lost a lot of
their you know they see their
value of their investments going down
and here along comes ben says
let's go right and i was fortunate i
found some
uh people that really bought into into
what i wanted to do they bought into me
remember i'd never been i'd never been a
vc before so i was really
jumping in some uh into something new
and and
and people really had to get behind me
but they did um
and so that that's why you know i just
thought the timing was
was really good to jump in um
by the way at that time i uh i was
meeting with vcs in israel and
um i was living in the states um but i
met modi
and he was one of the guys who
encouraged me and says
you're a vc you should jump in you
should do it um so
uh so i did and um
and then the strategy is which has been
the same strategy for
all these years which is i'm looking for
always looking for teams that have some
real ingenuity from a technology
standpoint
that they seem to be the right team for
the mission that they're going after
that they're going after a big big being
disrupted
and and again the timing seems right and
i don't care if it's
contrary and if everyone's running in
that direction or not running in that
direction
but if i feel if i have those
ingredients um
then it makes sense to you know to jump
in and invest in cups so
the right team for the right mission so
a lot of times i hear of them of these
as two fragmented questions
is this a good team is this a good
problem to solve
i i don't often hear the integration of
the two as as
sort of look at this as a machine
learning model and think of it as a
unique feature on its own
they integrate that it's the right team
for the right problem
right what does that actually mean to
you so to me it's like
you see that all the right uh a lot of
the skill sets that are needed from uh
maybe from a technology standpoint
is there or maybe there's some
experience with uh on the marketing side
you know if i do if i take successful
investments like let's take innoviz
as an example so why are they the right
team for the mission
maybe most people would look at it in
2016 and say
they don't seem like the right team for
the mission to go out after the
automotive industry and build the core
sensor that will enable
semi-autonomous and autonomous cars but
i looked at them
and uh first of all they came from
great experience from having worked
together in the 81 unit which to me
means you know how to really build
products
they knew each other well they each had
certain technologies that they knew that
was very a lidar is a combination of a
lot of technologies
and um in their previous startups or
what they've done in the unit were
was the type of technology background
that you needed
and then on the business side while
there wasn't much i'm still
like for example if i take oren one of
the co-founders
he had been working at bcg and they had
some automotive clients and he had some
knowledge of you know kind of where to
focus from uh the market and
and we actually worked together and
trying to figure out what's the
addressable market what's the market
timing and stuff like that
and when you looked at the market
actually um you know some of my team
were
really against it because there were
some phds that had another company that
had
from uh from the west coast uh that had
uh
uh you know that seemed that maybe they
might be state of the art leading edge
and
you know my view was uh if i have to bet
you know guys coming out 81 versus phds
and you have to build a very complex
product i'd always go with the
the 81 team so that's how i saw it was
the right team for the mission and i
knew that they could
immediately attract tens and tens of and
then eventually hundreds
of the most talented engineers so they
were magnets
um so that to me was the definition of
the right team for the mission
maybe others would say i want someone
that's automotive that's worked at
bmw yeah that's not the right team for
the mission for me
it's like those types of ingredients
that i you know
it's a take some intuition but that's
kind of how i looked at it and so now
we're
in 2021 it's the third fund
and the innovation just like a lot of
other companies incredible companies
thinking forward israel you're you're
very involved in the israeli ecosystem
you're talking about 81 8200
a lot of the you know the different
experiences that israelis may have that
may provide them an edge in in going and
executing on these really challenging
problems not just academically but
tangibly in the market
where where in your eyes are we headed
you've seen we've seen this growth for
10 years
what needs to happen so that israel can
maintain its competitive edge
in these regards because we're seeing a
lot of other countries advancing and a
lot of incredible people coming
and doing amazing things right so first
i'll talk a little bit what i see
currently and then also go in future
uh currently um
when uh i kind of see israel and silicon
valley actually
creating even more of a gap with the
rest of the world right now
and i say that because you know we've
obviously gone through the year of uh
the tragedy of covet 19 um
which also helped accelerate a lot of
things like
um online retail telemedicine etc
uh and we also saw a movement from
on-prem to cloud
and and then we also saw from a software
perspective moving from like monolithic
software to microservices etc
software is fundamentally changing and
if you look at the israeli companies
like whenever the cloud providers are
putting out a new feature
you see the israeli companies grabbing
it first playing with it
adopting it and then making it better
right and so
when i look at what are the key
technology trends i see
both the valley and israel as the these
are the teams that are being the early
adopters and grabbing it okay
if i just take that one example of
microservices and
going from monolithic software to you
know to breaking it into services
and and and and all the shift left and
development tools and cyber security
that's needed for it
you don't see it happening in europe you
don't see it happening in other parts of
the world
um but you see it like like in silicon
valley in israel it seems like it's
mainstream
when actually i think we're like in the
first inning of a nine-inning game
right of of these technologies but um
but israel's just racing ahead so that's
why i see with that with cyber security
semiconductors there's certain sectors
where is with data
compute uh certain sectors where israel
is really moving
very nicely along and of course always
with silicon valley too
in that symbiotic relationship um and
and and
creating a bigger gap between them and
the and the rest of the world so that's
what's exciting
long-term i mean israel definitely has
every country has its challenges
uh we have challenges here i think the
education system is
not what it needs to be so um both from
k through 12
and at the universities and keeping the
best professors and you know
from phds post docs researchers etc
we need to keep trying to do much better
get
much a lot more resources and get much
higher quality
uh people you know a teaching profession
should not be a volunteer it should be
that
you should be able to live well and be
and educate the youth in the country
um so i think that's you know one and
then of course
integrating all the communities i mean
we have to
first of all we have to do a big push on
on women issues and
you know gender equality we need to uh
obviously get the ultra orthodox and the
arab community much more involved in
in high tech uh i think those are our
critical things
now why why i agree but why are they
critical things in your in your eyes
because until now we're talking about
a very specific small subset of the
israeli ecosystem right we're talking
about
you know when we say you know 881
graduates or 8200 graduates we're
talking about hundreds of people
not millions right here and here you're
saying alongside in order to keep the
momentum and
com keep the competitive edge we need to
account for the entire population and
integrate them into
society and into the professional
society why is that why is that
important of course from uh society's
standpoint i think we're
we're in a a dangerous place both in
israel and united states and yeah in
many places around the world is that
there's two economies okay
in israel coming out of covid the tech
sector thrived we took
off we weren't worried about our jobs in
fact we couldn't find enough engineers
enough people to
fill jobs okay but yet the other part of
the israeli economy
you know and whether it's israel or the
united states is the same but
the other part of the israeli economy
really really suffered
uh for this past year lots of
unemployment
um a lot of displacement it was it was
tough
still is and it still is and and one of
the best solutions is
bring them into tech we can we're
outsourcing so much
to other countries there's no reason
it's better if we're all working in the
same office and building our r d
center is bigger and bigger so um
so being able to bring we need these
communities to get in because we don't
have enough
we're not gonna have enough engineers to
continue to scale up
so if we want to continue to scale up we
need
uh uh these communities to come in in
addition to that
i would also say you know we have to
think about our immigration policy too
um you know the best engineers in the
world wake up in the morning saying
i want to get myself to silicon valley
and compete against the best okay
but they would also love to come here
too so why not take
five thousand ten thousand of the best
engineers every year
and and give them a path to citizenship
in israel you know right
so um so i think if we want to remain
as if we want to be a superpower and
tech in israel
we have to get all the communities
involved we have to get the best
engineers to want to be here
um because we clearly have the
entrepreneurial spirit
the know-how the guts you know to to
build great companies
right um so those are the things that i
think we need to do and i love the
distinction about the the idea of
scaling up and i think
we're at a sort of inflection point and
i think really january of 2021 has been
an
inflection point where we're seeing you
know the number of companies that
that that declared going public or
through a spec
merger just in january of 2021 is half
the companies that ever went public
you know from the israel ecosystem and
we're seeing you know scale-up nation
instead of exit nation or startup nation
and this whole question of you know
building the r d we haven't seen really
israeli companies
building thousands of people r d centers
in israel
and and this is something that's pretty
fresh to the ecosystem and as a fresh
young entrepreneur i'm excited to see
you know
how this how this ecosystem is evolving
and it's pretty exciting
here you're meeting you know hundreds of
companies a year hundreds of
you know early stage companies later
stages sometimes but
what are some things that you're
observing as you're meeting founders
because i i imagine that pretty quickly
you know whether you want to advance and
pretty quickly you have some
you're developing some intuitions yeah
what are some of the
of the sort of the do's and don'ts and
in your eyes okay
um so first of all i agree about the the
scaling i think just actually if you
take the second fund of amity
um you should know this in the next
month or two but basically half of our
companies will be unicorns
half of the companies and uh
yeah so um so we're
um again there's something right now
we're almost half but we will be we'll
make i think we're going to make it
there within the next month or two
big news are coming okay yeah so um
in terms of what we're looking for i
mean first of all
you know it's uh there's usually two or
three people you know founders
um and it's really important that
they're all strong and they're all
um it's kind of the right team they
they've known each other for a while
they didn't just like
date essentially over the last two
months and now they're meeting with us
you know if they've worked together
in the past that's a huge huge value um
we actually like uh we of course like
serial entrepreneurs
but statistically we're better investors
with first-timers
really um so we left because
first-timers
are there's so much passion their
company become
is their identity this is like what
they're thinking about
24 7. um and so we really do love
the first timers and we also love when
they
realize that they don't have to find
like maybe it's two guys and they've
been working together in the past and
they're
you know both technical and someone says
oh you need to now go find
your business person and we think that's
really bad advice
um as long as one person is
even if they're both introverts if one
person can fake
being an extrovert from time to time uh
then that's good enough
and um and we'd much rather because
when you bring in a business person and
you say okay this person's gonna be the
ceo
the ceo actually makes all the critical
the key decisions
so when there's a a trade-off on what
feature to do or what to do with the
product or to
to pivot or which customers to focus on
or
you know you're handing that over to
someone who
you know is looking at this as a kind of
like okay it's a nice gig
for me to do next um we'd rather you
if you have two people three people and
you're like you've worked together and
you're excited
you know go go try to do it by yourself
before trying to bring in
uh you know a business person is there
something that ticks you off
something that some things that you know
maybe frustrate you throughout the
process or
that you feel like ah like why you
didn't have to do that
okay so one obviously is when a great
technical
founder joins with a business person
that is not
that impressive that's frustrating um
but the uh
the other thing is um look we love to
brainstorm
with and and if the point of the meeting
is to just brainstorm then that's great
if you're coming to a meeting because
you're actually wanting to raise money
right now
and you're not really prepared and what
i mean by prepared is
you don't know your market that well i
mean i don't care about what the slides
look like that's really
not important to me okay um and
uh so what is knowing what what does it
mean to know
you've spoken to potential customers
you've spoken to
whoever's in in the middle of the value
chain and the partners
um you you didn't just have like a good
meeting with someone and they said yeah
if you had that that would be really
cool
but they like it's a real pain like they
you're you're solving a big problem and
they said
give it to me make this right away and i
want to be your design partner
um that's what we want to hear but if
you're just sad like look i have 30
logos i've talked to all these people
and all you really had was a 20-minute
conversation or a 15-minute conversation
here and there
um that's not so interesting um
you know if you show me a data point it
says this market's going to be 50
billion dollars but you
have no way to tell me how you justify
why it's
that big even if or a billion dollars or
whatever it is
um so just know the market like what's
you know
it's also okay to say i don't have no
idea what the potential is but i know
that i'm solving a real problem
right you know that i'm i'm fine with
that you know so
so know the customer know the market and
then
and then with the technology really know
it so if you're going to talk about
oh yeah we're going to do ai and machine
learning we're going to be asking you
we're going to drill you like to see
like exactly what you're doing
and so yeah and a lot of times we find
out that there's actually no
ai required right to do the product so
um so i think those are are some of the
things but
again if it's a brainstorming discussion
if we set it up that way
we'd love to help companies or founders
go through a couple months of
brainstorming before they're ready to
actually raise money
then then you don't need to be prepared
you know we'll help you think of how to
prepare
and that's the real due diligence it's
that relationship that you build over
months and you and you see how the
how the founders are working over over a
stretch of time and not over
a series of a few meetings which makes
it that makes the due diligence process
much harder
because there's a lot more question
marks that you're trying to fill in the
gap so it's like you're saying
you're seeing some words blackened out
and you're trying to fill in
from other spec extrapolate from other
data points that you have right
but the one way that we sharp which is
great about how you short circuit the
process in israel and
and this is where it's it's not fair but
it's i mean it's
it is what it is is that those that do
come from the units
okay our ability to very quickly figure
out
what did your commander think what did
the other team leaders think of you what
did your soldiers think of you
um did did you really work together on a
project together or did you
you know pass each other in a hallway
you know right um and when you were
working in
in your in the same unit you know um we
can
the one of the great things from
investing in israel is we can
short-circuit the process of due
diligence
so quickly uh because it's a essentially
a
a small community one degree of
celebration right
whereas in the states that there's
someone from georgia who work who's
teamed up with someone from seattle and
they uh
they got a third founder in la and now
they've kind of come together
how do you you know right how do you
have the tools to figure
you know it's so much easier here i mean
there are ways to do that obviously
there's really good vcs in the us that
invest in
us companies but it's a lot easier you
know you know to do it here
completely agree ben are you ready for
some fun questions okay i'll try
all right first one favorite subject in
school
all right a little boring but um i loved
history i love history yeah
um i love uh um
just seeing what how leaders dealt with
very tough
uh tough situations i love learning
about other countries other cultures
problems they had to deal with i think
we can learn a lot from history
uh i think it builds up our value system
because
as much as we like to think that all the
world's going in the wrong direction
and there are problems obviously in the
world but you know if you think about
like
what was the world really like in the
1960s and what was the world really like
you know
40s and well you know and or or 300
years ago
uh you realize that we're progressing so
so much on so many areas and we still
have a lot and of course
40 years from now we'll look at today's
period and say wow we were really
how would we drove cars you know but um
and how did we even think that way and
it's so immoral but
yes you know but uh so it's it's nice to
look over history and and and there's
things to be proud of and things to be
ashamed of but it's good to
learn from them to learn from them yeah
role model
so on this theme of history um i'll just
give a genre that i um
there are uh especially political
leaders that i've always looked at
and and in the ways political leaders
were the startups were the founders or
the
entrepreneurs of their day you know if
you think about in israel of course uh
david ben-gurion of course he was in a
way an entrepreneur building a
country and having to make super hard
decisions you know if you look at an
abraham lincoln or winston churchill
there's so many leaders in the past
or if you look at a martin luther king
what he was able to do when he was
31 32 years old and be a leader of
a civil rights movement and inspire the
world
um yeah i i i kind of get a lot of
inspiration from those kind of leaders
and i love to read books
you know on them right yeah in three
words you choose to describe yourself
so first i'm definitely a dad or an alba
um
so that's the first thing i think about
when i wake up in the morning and it's
uh
it's my top priority so um so everything
else is uh
is a second to that um but then i would
say amity
like when you're an entrepreneur and
you're a founder
um you don't know the difference in the
identity between the name of
of of the company you've built in and
who you are like i don't know
what's been what's on me t it's like
it's all together
um and that's not the origin of the name
i mean the origin of the name is um
actually my daughter and i did this like
she was like nine years old at the time
and or 10 years old and we spent
basically two
hours working on it uh really so um
i'll give a big secret to the world
which is always start your company with
a
letter a or an olive because you want to
present
at conferences early um but um
the otherwise we were looking for
something that was easy to say in
english that had a nice hebrew meaning
and was an acronym and we uh i was
in chicago we were living in chicago and
we were raising money in chicago
so we thought okay accelerating midwest
israel technology investments
um and that combined with we like the
meaning in hebrew
it was easy to say in english and that's
that's how we ended up with that
um so so that was two that was two um
we have dad we have amity and i would
just say
um you know just
uh it's something between i don't know
it's
this it's hard i'm choosing between
resilience
focus and also thinking big there's a
lot of slashes in between a lot of
passions between those without
you know all those kind of things thank
you very very much
i love what you guys are doing here uh
it's i i love the process and i love the
the strategic thinking playing offense
in 2010
and when everybody's playing defense but
thinking critically about
you know the israeli ecosystem not just
as the tech ecosystem but a society and
how
society together is is a part of the
israeli story
of both the startup nation but also the
scale-up nation to working with the
founders and understanding what does it
mean to have a good team
and for the right problem and and
measuring that team through
through a real relationship process and
not just through a transactional meeting
where you're trying to evaluate whether
the
whether the united economics are working
i just love the whole mindset
and obviously the origin of the word of
meeting
that's the best part of all great well
thanks so much for coming and i like how
you personalize things and
get everyone to see each other as an
individual and part of
doing the larger good thank you very
much
you